Well well well hello welcome to another bonus episode of how we made your mother a GQ as we're calling it around the shop.
好吧好吧，你好，欢迎收看我们如何让你的母亲成为 GQ（我们在商店里这么称呼它）的另一集奖励。
I think people on the streets people are really calling it that now It's really popular to call into GQ's.
我认为街上的人真的都这么称呼它，现在打电话给 GQ 真的很流行。
They're calling it GQ.
他们称之为GQ。
Maybe they just don't want to salute.
也许他们只是不想敬礼。
Maybe you want to avoid the salute GQ you can develop salute elbow, which is you gotta you know, but we all have it.
也许你想避免敬礼GQ，你可以开发敬礼肘，这是你必须知道的，但我们都有。
We all have it that we all suffering from it.
我们都拥有它，我们都遭受它的痛苦。
That's why we just, it's the elbow sort of a general pain all around the general pain.
这就是为什么我们只是说，这是肘部的一种全身疼痛，周围都是全身疼痛。
General pain!
一般痛！
But let's do it with our non-dominant elbow.
但让我们用非优势肘部来做这件事。
Welcome, this is a general question.
欢迎，这是一个一般性问题。
General question, that's the worst.
一般问题，这是最糟糕的。
On episode 18, nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
在第 18 集，凌晨 2 点之后没有什么好事发生。
We had a great talk about that, a couple of days ago, I hope you tuned into that.
几天前我们对此进行了一次精彩的讨论，我希望您能关注这一点。
If you haven't listened to it already, maybe go listen to that and then pop back over here, or you know what, you're the master of your own life.
如果您还没有听过，也许可以去听一下，然后再回到这里，或者您知道吗，您是自己生活的主人。
You're living your own life.
你过着自己的生活。
You've got to do you.
你必须做你自己。
Listen to whatever you order you want.
听你想要的任何命令。
But it's a private choice.
但这是私人选择。
You do.
你做。
You just do it.
你就这么做吧。
You're trying to trick us.
你想欺骗我们。
I don't think they get private.
我不认为他们会变得私密。
You don't salute private.
你不向私人致敬。
We don't salute private.
我们不向私人致敬。
I don't do it.
我不做。
It depends on what rank we are in our lives.
这取决于我们在生活中的地位。
We're nothing.
我们什么都不是。
Okay.
好的。
So let me do salute private.
那么请允许我私下敬礼。
Okay.
好的。
Here we go.
开始了。
Well, okay.
好吧，好吧。
So Alec, how were the questions this week for nothing good happens after?
那么亚历克，这周的问题怎么样，因为之后没有什么好事发生？
Great stuff.
很棒的东西。
And you know, kind of big stuff, heavy stuff is this episode as it did for you guys prompts some big heavy things and some smaller things.
你知道，这一集是一些大事、沉重的事情，就像它为你们所做的那样，提示了一些大而沉重的事情和一些较小的事情。
I'm just gonna read you a quick story.
我只是要给你读一个简短的故事。
This is the drama, this is the drama episode, this one.
这是戏剧，这是戏剧情节，这一集。
This is just someone that has their own, I'm sure you guys have been approached with many of your very own, nothing good happens after 2 a.m., kind of stories over the decades.
这只是一个有自己故事的人，我相信你们也遇到过很多自己的故事，凌晨两点之后就没有什么好事发生了，几十年来的故事。
This is a lovely one.
这是一件可爱的事。
Deborah Rose from Facebook says, glad Ted the Liar got what he deserved at the end of this episode, okay.
Facebook 的黛博拉·罗斯 (Deborah Rose) 表示，很高兴说谎者泰德在这一集结束时得到了他应得的，好吧。
Is that my head on Liar?
这就是我对说谎者的看法吗？
That's for my dad.
那是给我爸爸的。
Ted the Liar, here we go.
骗子特德，我们走吧。
the gloves are often me not legendary being honest and faithful is a difficult choice and when I've had to make in the past I saw a lot of parallels to my own experience in this episode in the end I made the decision to be true to my partner instead of sleeping with a rock star little did I know that my partner who was in Australia broke up with me in a letter that had been mailed but not arrived in the US at the time of my relationship test so technically I was already broken up with but I didn't know it.
手套常常是我不传奇的诚实和忠诚是一个艰难的选择，当我过去不得不做出的时候，我在这一集中看到了很多与我自己的经历相似的地方，最后我决定忠于我的伴侣，而不是和摇滚明星上床。我几乎不知道我在澳大利亚的伴侣在一封已邮寄但在我的关系测试时尚未到达美国的信中与我分手，所以从技术上讲我已经分手了，但我不知道。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I still kind of regret not hopping on that base player, but I'm glad I practiced my integrity and good sense.
我仍然有点后悔没有跳到那个基础球员身上，但我很高兴我练习了我的正直和良好的判断力。
And it was only around 1 30 a.m.
当时才凌晨 1 点 30 分左右。
anyway.
反正。
That is every part of that letter was exhausting.
那封信的每一部分都让人筋疲力尽。
I needed a nap halfway through that letter.
那封信读到一半我需要小睡一下。
That was, I mean, it was a great narrative twist and turns.
我的意思是，这是一个伟大的叙事曲折。
Yeah.
是的。
Very juicy.
非常多汁。
Well, it's funny that she is so angry at Ted, but she herself is like, I wish I had known So I could have done it.
好吧，有趣的是她对特德如此生气，但她自己就像，我希望我早知道这样我就可以做到这一点。
I should have banged that bass player.
我应该敲那个贝斯手的。
Now my mind is racing.
现在我的思绪飞快。
What bass player?
什么贝斯手？
We're just now.
我们只是现在。
I'm totally out there.
我完全在外面。
Who was it?
是谁？
It was a flea.
那是一只跳蚤。
But that's just a flavor of the kind of letters.
但这只是这类信件的一种风格。
Sure.
当然。
That's just a flavor.
那只是一种味道。
And I was also saying that for the face.
我也是为了面子才这么说的。
You also join the How We Major Mother Facebook group.
您还可以加入 How We Major Mother Facebook 群组。
Is that what the letter is for?
这就是这封信的目的吗？
That came from the Facebook group.
这是来自 Facebook 群组的。
I asked for questions just like two hours ago.
我就在两个小时前问过问题。
Boy.
男生。
Talk about putting some skin in the event.
谈论在事件中加入一些皮肤。
skin of the game.
游戏的皮肤。
That is a great, yeah, that that letter was written with all all in.
是的，这封信是全心全意写的，这真是太棒了。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
Well, it's also a nice example of how a show like how a mother is hitting on things that were that continue to be so perennially relevant and real.
嗯，这也是一个很好的例子，说明像《母亲》这样的节目如何触及那些始终如此相关和真实的事物。
You know, these questions of like, are you in the right relationship?
你知道，这些问题比如，你们的关系好吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Can you make long distance work?
可以做长途工作吗？
What if, you know, the person you've loved forever kind of comes back and wants to start something, but you're something else.
如果，你知道，你永远爱的人回来并想要开始做某事，但你却是另外一个人，该怎么办？
Like, these are all like ever green, ever green things and we've all almost had sex with flea at some point.
就像，这些都是常青常绿的东西，我们都几乎在某个时候与跳蚤发生过性关系。
But the best stories turn the narrative back on the spotlight back on you and go, when have I been in this situation?
但最好的故事会将叙事重新聚焦在你身上，然后说，我什么时候遇到过这种情况？
How did I behave?
我表现如何？
Did I make the right move?
我的举动正确吗？
You know, if it gets your mind racing, then we did something right.
你知道，如果这让你头脑发热，那么我们做对了。
So thank Thank you for sharing your racing mind about this one.
所以谢谢你分享你对此的想法。
No, Craig, you I heard you on Monday's show a glance gloss over Robin's choice at the beginning of this or end of the previous episode and Kurt Kurt Kurt K tank wants to follow up on that.
不，克雷格，我听到你在周一的节目中对罗宾在本集开头或上一集结尾处的选择进行了掩饰，库尔特·库尔特·库尔特·坦克想跟进这一点。
Every rewatch makes me think more and more that Robin is to blame and has no right to get.
每次重看都让我越来越觉得罗宾应该受到责备，并且没有权利受到责备。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Ultimately, she knew exactly what she was doing when she called Ted.
最终，当她打电话给特德时，她清楚地知道自己在做什么。
Is this the underlying intention of how it's written, or did you purposely leave it up to interpretation?
这是它的写作方式的潜在意图，还是你故意将其留给解释？
What about Robin?
罗宾呢？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I mean, it's true.
嗯，我的意思是，这是真的。
It's like, I feel like any look, and all your favorite movies and plays and books, like it's way more interesting if no one's all the way right and no one's all the way wrong, right?
就像，我觉得任何造型，以及所有你最喜欢的电影、戏剧和书籍，如果没有人完全正确，也没有人完全错误，那就更有趣了，对吧？
It's like, I think that's what makes it juicy.
就像，我认为这就是让它多汁的原因。
It's like, boy, she does sort of walk off on the moral high ground at the end of the episode compared to what Ted has done.
就像，天哪，与特德所做的相比，她在这一集结束时确实走上了道德制高点。
And when you remove it when compared to what Ted has done, she did call him at 2 AM, feeling very like lonely and lost, knowing at that time they had a girlfriend and he showed up.
当你把它与泰德所做的相比时，她确实在凌晨 2 点给他打电话，感觉非常孤独和失落，知道那时他们有一个女朋友，而且他出现了。
She doesn't know he's quote unquote broken up with Victoria or got dumped by Victoria, which is not true.
她不知道他和维多利亚分手了，或者被维多利亚甩了，这不是真的。
She doesn't know that until he's been there for a little bit.
直到他在那里呆了一段时间她才知道这一点。
And that's what makes it so interesting.
这就是它如此有趣的原因。
She's, and then right, I mean, like, the end of the season is the new challenges.
她是的，我的意思是，赛季结束就是新的挑战。
Do these two characters, how do these two characters get together after this?
这两个角色，这两个角色之后会如何走到一起呢？
or do they, and I think it is interesting to note that Robin was not all the way right here either.
或者他们确实这么做了，我认为有趣的是罗宾也不是完全在这里。
And that gave, that left the door open for what comes at the end of season one.
这就为第一季结束时的情况敞开了大门。
I also think there's a little, there's like a human thing where you're like, how close can I get to the rail?
我还认为有一点，就像人类的事情一样，我可以离铁轨多近？
Like how close can I get my finger to the stove without getting burned?
比如我的手指距离炉子多近才不会被烫伤？
Can I just get close enough to feel the heat of it?
我可以靠得足够近来感受它的热量吗？
Like, I think that's what the hug is.
就像，我想这就是拥抱。
It's like, no, we're just hugging.
就像，不，我们只是拥抱。
We're friends who are hugging.
我们是拥抱的朋友。
Oh, this hug is going on a long time, you know?
哦，这个拥抱要持续很长时间，你知道吗？
Like, I think- Inching up to the cliff.
就像，我想——慢慢爬上悬崖。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
It's inching up and just peering over it.
它正在缓慢地向上移动并凝视着它。
Enough to feel the, oh, that sinking feeling in your stomach that you're about to fall.
足以感觉到，哦，你的胃里那种下沉的感觉，你快要摔倒了。
So I think we test limits in that way.
所以我认为我们以这种方式测试极限。
We're trying to maintain plausible deniability while at the same time trying to not be alone or trying to win some affections.
我们试图保持貌似合理的否认，同时努力不孤单或试图赢得一些感情。
Because sometimes I know a guy who, he told me, he said, I wanted this woman to come over kind of late at night.
因为有时我认识一个人，他告诉我，他说，我希望这个女人在深夜过来。
And this is not me, by the way, it sounds like I knew a guy.
顺便说一句，这不是我，听起来我认识一个人。
It's really, this is not me.
真的，这不是我。
This is a guy I know.
这是我认识的一个人。
He said, I wanted this woman to come over late at night.
他说，我想让这个女人深夜过来。
When she told me I just ordered an Uber, I'm coming over, he immediately wanted her to not come over because all he wanted was for her to say, I'm getting an Uber and I'm coming over.
当她告诉我我刚刚订了一辆优步，我要过来时，他立即希望她不要过来，因为他只想让她说，我要一辆优步，我要过来。
Like he didn't actually need to see her.
就好像他其实并不需要见她一样。
He needed to know she would come.
他需要知道她会来。
Right.
正确的。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
There are varying degrees of what we need.
我们需要的东西有不同程度的。
Like it's not all about like ending up in bed together.
好像这并不只是最后一起上床。
Sometimes we just want the affection or the presence of someone or for them to look at us a certain way or say certain things to us.
有时我们只是想要某人的感情或在场，或者让他们以某种方式看待我们或对我们说某些事情。
So I think Robin just like, she needed to be close to him in that moment.
所以我认为罗宾就像，在那一刻她需要靠近他。
And yeah, but she was also playing with fire just like he was.
是的，但她也像他一样在玩火。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, they said that like the fear of heights is the fear of that you control and throw yourself off that sort of and it's there's something it's there's some inching up to that ledge to sort of see what's going to happen with on both sides of the equation here, which is what makes it interesting, I think.
嗯，他们说，就像对高处的恐惧一样，你会害怕你控制自己并把自己从那种地方扔掉，而且有一些东西，那就是有一些东西慢慢地爬到那个壁架上，看看等式两边会发生什么，我认为这就是让它变得有趣的原因。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了在纽约为你唱歌。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at Hyper-FixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 Hyper-FixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
Brian Del Pozzo from also from Facebook says, it's relatively rare to see a sitcom have the lead protagonists act in quite such an unequivocally wrong way as Ted does was their pushback either from the members of the show's creative team, the cast, or the network.
同样来自 Facebook 的布莱恩·德尔·波佐 (Brian Del Pozzo) 表示，情景喜剧中主角的行为方式像泰德 (Ted) 那样明显错误的情况很少见，因为他们受到了节目创意团队成员、演员或网络的抵制。
I mean, no, I think the student in the network, they were pretty cool about realizing like, this is juicy, this is drama.
我的意思是，不，我认为网络中的学生，他们很酷地意识到，这很有趣，这是戏剧。
We know Ted loves Robin, Ted is not just trying to hook up and have a one night stand.
我们知道泰德爱罗宾，泰德不仅仅是想勾搭上一夜情。
He does have deep real feelings for her, which I think I don't agree with the word unequivocally in that question.
他确实对她有很深的真实感情，我想我不同意这个问题中的明确说法。
I appreciate the question.
我很欣赏这个问题。
I think it's a smart question.
我认为这是一个聪明的问题。
And I think it's a question.
我认为这是一个问题。
It's true.
这是真的。
Most sitcoms don't show this, right?
大多数情景喜剧都不会展示这一点，对吗？
This feels more like a drama, this one, in a good way, I think, but it's not unequivocally wrong.
我认为，这感觉更像是一部戏剧，以一种好的方式，但这并不是明确的错误。
Ted is not.
特德不是。
I think we've made the case for 17 episodes prior to this 18th episode that this is not unequivocally wrong.
我认为我们已经在第 18 集之前的 17 集中证明了这并不是明确错误的。
That's my take.
这就是我的看法。
I mean, two things.
我的意思是，有两件事。
One is it's Robin, right?
一是罗宾，对吧？
that catchphrase he invokes to let himself out of jail all the time.
他总是用这句话来让自己出狱。
It's Robin, I can throw out the plan, I can throw out my ethics.
是罗宾，我可以放弃这个计划，我可以放弃我的道德。
But the other thing that really strikes me as like, he keeps telling his kids, this is the worst thing I ever did.
但真正让我印象深刻的另一件事是，他不断告诉他的孩子们，这是我做过的最糟糕的事情。
Which, by the way, I think you could go through the series and maybe this isn't the worst thing he's ever done.
顺便说一句，我认为你可以看完这个系列，也许这并不是他做过的最糟糕的事情。
Almost certainly not, it might not be in the top five of like when you get in the last analysis, like if you're ranking his worst moments, you know?
几乎肯定不会，当你进行最后的分析时，它可能不会进入前五名，就像你对他最糟糕的时刻进行排名一样，你知道吗？
Yeah, I think that's right, I think that's right.
是的，我认为是对的，我认为是对的。
But he does present this to his kids and thus to the audience as your old man screwed up.
但他确实把这个呈现给他的孩子们，从而呈现给观众，因为你的老人搞砸了。
Like this was not my finest hour.
好像这不是我最好的时刻。
And I think that gives him a little cover.
我认为这给了他一点掩护。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
And I think, nothing's unequivocal, I think in life.
我认为，生活中没有什么是明确的。
That's what I'm trying to say.
这就是我想说的。
I think nothing's unequivocal, which is why this episode hits because everybody is at moments like this.
我认为没有什么是明确的，这就是为什么这一集很受欢迎，因为每个人都会有这样的时刻。
And this idea that you kind of are, it's almost like a werewolf narrative too.
你的这个想法，也几乎就像一个狼人的故事。
I keep on it.
我继续坚持下去。
We said it's sort of a suspense movie.
我们说这是一部悬疑电影。
It's sort of a ghost movie.
这有点像鬼片。
It's also a werewolf narrative.
这也是一个狼人的故事。
It's like that full moon.
就像那满月一样。
Watch out for that full moon.
留意那个满月。
Do not feed those those cute little magwai after is that the right word after midnight.
午夜过后，不要喂那些可爱的小马格瓦伊，这是正确的词。
They're going to become gremlins.
他们将成为小魔怪。
Like there's almost something supernatural about 2 a.m.
就像凌晨两点左右发生了一些超自然的事情一样
and about late night decision making.
以及深夜的决策。
We've all done it.
我们都做到了。
Everyone has done it in some category or multiple categories.
每个人都在某个类别或多个类别中做过。
Someone has had a night.
有人度过了一夜。
They look back on.
他们回头看。
They go, that was not my best that was not my best self, and it's universal, and that's why I think it's not unequivocally wrong.
他们说，这不是我最好的，这不是我最好的自己，这是普遍的，这就是为什么我认为这并不是明确错误的。
It's actually very human.
这实际上非常人性化。
And it almost feels like your 20s are the decade designated for those kinds of screw-ups.
几乎感觉二十几岁就是发生这类事情的十年。
Like, you know, because you have to figure, it's like that phrase, you don't know what enough is until you'd have had more than enough.
就像，你知道，因为你必须弄清楚，就像那句话一样，你不知道什么是足够，直到你拥有了足够多的东西。
Like you're testing boundaries.
就像你在测试界限一样。
Like you're testing your own boundaries.
就像你在测试自己的界限一样。
Like, what would it be like, what's it like to drink, you know, 13 beers and try to go to work in the morning?
比如说，喝 13 瓶啤酒然后尝试早上去上班会是什么样子？
like it didn't work, not good.
好像没用，不好。
You know, like, you've got to try to figure out like who you are and what your kind of recipe is for living.
你知道，你必须试着弄清楚你是谁，以及你的生活秘诀是什么。
And your 20s are where you really experiment in ways that are sometimes disastrous and oftentimes illuminating.
二十多岁的时候，你会真正尝试一些有时是灾难性的，但有时却很有启发性的方法。
Yeah, but make it for a good story.
是的，但是要写一个好故事。
Brian continues this question and it's a really, I think a really great writing structure question, writing question.
布莱恩继续这个问题，我认为这是一个非常好的写作结构问题，写作问题。
He says, also, do you feel the show's unique framing device, essentially allowing future Ted to judge his actions from 30 years in the future, softens the blow of 2005 Ted's douchey behavior.
他还说，你是否觉得这部剧独特的框架设计，本质上是让未来的泰德在未来 30 年后判断他的行为，减轻了 2005 年泰德的愚蠢行为的打击。
It doesn't work without the narrator.
没有叙述者就行不通。
It doesn't work.
这不起作用。
There's no episode.
没有一集啊
Well, there's no, this whole show doesn't work without the narrator, but nothing that happens after 2 a.m.
好吧，不，如果没有旁白，整个节目就无法进行，但是凌晨 2 点之后就不会发生任何事情了。
is a retrospective slot.
是一个追溯槽。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
He's Ted's ignoring that in the moment.
他是特德此刻忽略了这一点。
And it is older, wiser advice from his own mother, Kourtney Kang's mother actually, the arbiter Kourtney Kang's mother used to say that to her.
这是来自他自己的母亲，实际上是考特尼·康的母亲的更古老、更明智的建议，仲裁员考特尼·康的母亲曾经对她说过这样的话。
And he's featured Ted is now more like what his mom's age was when she was telling him that or older.
他所介绍的特德现在更像是他妈妈告诉他这件事时的年龄，或者更老。
And so it only worked.
所以它才起作用。
The whole episode only works, I think, because of that.
我认为，整个情节之所以有效，就是因为这个。
So I think it is a good observation and it would be a totally different feeling if we didn't have that.
所以我认为这是一个很好的观察，如果我们没有这样的感觉，那将会是一种完全不同的感觉。
Joe LaFever, also from Facebook, was so sad today.
同样来自 Facebook 的 Joe LaFever 今天非常难过。
Okay, what was the inspiration behind Victoria?
好吧，维多利亚背后的灵感是什么？
The idea that Ted follows the risk-reward pathway in regard to a potential new feeling of love is very symbolic of how the dating scene is.
泰德在潜在的新的爱的感觉方面遵循风险回报途径的想法非常具有约会场景的象征意义。
You never really know who you're meeting, which I guess is what they were trying to cut out, the idea of not having to know.
你永远不会真正知道你会见谁，我猜这就是他们试图消除的，即不必知道的想法。
This episode really lays down the fundamentals of Ted being so blinded by love and having so much to work on in that department.
这一集确实奠定了泰德被爱情蒙蔽双眼以及在该部门有很多工作要做的基础。
In a way, we've all been Ted as we learn the right kind of love and grow.
在某种程度上，当我们学习正确的爱并成长时，我们都是泰德。
That's a good point.
这是一个很好的观点。
I think that current day Ted is imagining some wonderful future that is so wonderful, it will justify dubious behavior in the present.
我认为今天的特德正在想象一些美好的未来，它是如此美好，它会证明现在可疑的行为是合理的。
He's using the future to pay for now.
他正在用未来来偿还现在。
It is like bad, it's sort of bad finance.
这就像糟糕的事情，有点糟糕的财务状况。
It's like, we're gonna be rich in the future so we can run up debt now.
就像，我们将来会变得富有，所以我们现在可以负债累累。
Well, it's almost like utopianists who will justify horrifying human rights abuses because they're fighting for the better world, right?
好吧，这几乎就像乌托邦主义者一样，他们会为可怕的侵犯人权行为辩护，因为他们正在为更美好的世界而战，对吗？
It's sadly not that far off from that.
遗憾的是，离这个目标并不遥远。
like the sort of delusional, it'll all be so great, it'll justify this.
就像那种妄想，一切都会那么美好，它会证明这一点。
Ted is basically the, he's the idiomene of characters.
泰德基本上就是，他是人物的惯用语。
Oh man, there's your, there's your quote, there's your word for the show.
噢，伙计，这是你的，这是你的引言，这是你对节目的台词。
This is one that actually, I'm going to say it to you guys, it's probably a Steve Olson question.
实际上，我要对你们说，这可能是史蒂夫·奥尔森的问题。
So, you know, hi, Steve, we know Steve is listening, who was your, what was his title production designer?
所以，你知道，嗨，史蒂夫，我们知道史蒂夫在听，谁是你的，他的制作设计师头衔是什么？
Production designer.
生产设计师。
Steve, yeah.
史蒂夫，是的。
So I love you winning.
所以我爱你获胜。
I mean you get so many perspectives on who is watching the show and who is getting what from it Here's one that I just enjoyed from Jessica Wallace xo x so I believe has commented on many things on Instagram But takes this one personally.
我的意思是，你对谁在观看这部剧以及谁从这部剧中得到了什么有很多看法。这是我刚刚喜欢的杰西卡·华莱士 xo x 的一部，所以我相信她在 Instagram 上评论了很多事情，但我个人认为这是一部。
This is back on drumroll.
这又回到了鼓声中。
Please.
请。
A lot of people wrote about a lot of the Victoria Episodes here.
很多人在这里写了很多维多利亚剧集。
I'm a wedding planner and I've got to know what's the budget for the sets for episodes with weddings I see the floral arrangements and such and I know how expensive these things are and I wonder how it works for a fake wedding for a show So, we see that weddings look very high end for their time.
我是一名婚礼策划师，我必须知道婚礼剧集的布景预算是多少，我看到了插花等，我知道这些东西有多贵，我想知道它如何用于一场演出的假婚礼所以，我们看到婚礼在他们的时代看起来非常高端。
Do you know what the episode cost?
你知道这一集的费用是多少吗？
Wait, not this episode.
等等，不是这一集。
We're back to drumroll, please.
我们又回到鼓点了，拜托。
No, on this one.
不，就这一点而言。
A lot of these questions covered several of the different ones, also.
许多这些问题也涵盖了几个不同的问题。
And I think someone else pointed out who invites their wedding baker to the wedding to sit at the desk.
我想其他人指出谁邀请他们的婚礼面包师参加婚礼并坐在办公桌前。
Well, we know in the episode, the wedding cost $400,000, which is outrageously expensive, especially 20 years ago.
嗯，我们在剧集中知道，婚礼花费了 40 万美元，这是贵得离谱，尤其是在 20 年前。
It was a crazy, I was very surprised by that price especially, and I would say that what we shot did not look like it cost not much, whatever it costs, but just like a wedding.
这太疯狂了，我对这个价格感到非常惊讶，尤其是，我想说的是，我们拍摄的东西看起来并不花费多少钱，无论花费多少，但就像一场婚礼。
It was like a conference room at any old hotel.
这就像任何一家老酒店的会议室。
Yeah.
是的。
It looked like a hotel.
它看起来像一家酒店。
It looked good.
看起来不错。
It worked, but it didn't necessarily look like the most lavish wedding.
它确实有效，但看起来并不一定是最奢华的婚礼。
But yeah, we had to weigh those ideas, although I mean, you know, when I thought of this within this Victoria run is the joke in life among the gorillas, I guess, where Ted falls asleep on the phone with Victoria, right?
但是，是的，我们必须权衡这些想法，尽管我的意思是，你知道，当我想到维多利亚跑步中的这一点是大猩猩生活中的笑话时，我猜，特德在电话中与维多利亚睡着了，对吗？
And I remember thinking, as I was watching it, I was like, oh, it would have been funny, as I was watching it the other day, I would have been funny to cut Ashley on the other end of that call hearing Ted snoring, right?
我记得我当时在想，当我看它的时候，我想，哦，这会很有趣，因为我前几天在看它，如果我在电话的另一端听到泰德打鼾而切掉阿什利，那会很有趣，对吧？
And in Germany.
在德国。
And I thought we should have done that.
我认为我们应该这样做。
And I thought, that would have cost $30,000 that joke, right?
我想，这个笑话要花 30,000 美元，对吗？
We would have had to book Ashley Williams for an episode and pay her fee.
我们必须预订阿什利·威廉姆斯一集并支付她的费用。
We would have to create, I don't know, her apartment in Germany that she's in, or the Culinary Institute she's going in.
我不知道，我们必须建造她在德国的公寓，或者她要去的烹饪学院。
That would have been a five-figure joke.
那将是一个五位数的笑话。
That would have been tens of thousands of dollars for one joke, and that's why we didn't do it.
一个笑话就要花费数万美元，这就是我们没有这样做的原因。
And we were not a big hit.
我们并没有大受欢迎。
This was season one later in season five, season six, the show hits indication.
这是第一季，第五季、第六季之后，该剧就达到了预期。
And we were like, hey, we want to do this one cutaway that got $25,000, maybe, maybe when you're a hit, now when you're in season one.
我们当时想，嘿，我们想做这个能获得 25,000 美元的切角，也许，也许当你很受欢迎的时候，现在当你在第一季的时候。
Well, there's also so much about television, like you, your character could be contracted for seven out of 13, not for all of them.
好吧，关于电视的内容也有很多，就像你一样，你的角色可能会签约 13 个角色中的 7 个，而不是全部。
And you go, it's almost like, I think maybe he ended up in all of them later, but I don't know if like Buster was in all of the first 13 of the rest of the development.
你去吧，这几乎就像，我想也许他后来会出现在所有这些中，但我不知道巴斯特是否出现在开发的其余前 13 个中。
Because that deal was like a seven out of 13 or 10 out of 13, and people go, Well, why wasn't in Buster in there?
因为那笔交易就像 13 中的 7 或 13 中的 10，人们会说，好吧，为什么巴斯特不在其中？
It doesn't make sense.
这没有道理。
Because there was a deal.
因为有一笔交易。
They made a deal in place, right?
他们已经达成协议了，对吗？
It's a financial reality.
这是一个财务现实。
And it's true.
这是真的。
We didn't have Ashley booked for that episode, but wanted to keep Victoria alive just to get to where we've gotten to in this episode.
我们没有为阿什利预订这一集，但想让维多利亚活着，只是为了达到我们在这一集中所达到的目的。
And to get the feeling of long distance, having her not be seen is actually was a good feeling to have there in a way.
为了获得远距离的感觉，不被人看到她在某种程度上实际上是一种很好的感觉。
It helps the narrative that she becomes a little bit of a fading kind of vision.
她变得有点褪色，这有助于叙事。
Yes.
是的。
He even says, Ted says, I don't remember, right?
他甚至说，特德说，我不记得了，对吧？
In that episode, I don't quite remember her face, which actually felt like a very real thing.
在那一集中，我不太记得她的脸，但实际上感觉就像是一个非常真实的东西。
Finally, James Schmoesby, who sends a lot of great questions on Instagram.
最后是 James Schmoesby，他在 Instagram 上提出了很多很棒的问题。
I can't believe that's his last name.
我不敢相信这是他的姓氏。
I can't believe that's one of the oddest.
我不敢相信这是最奇怪的之一。
James says, as we're closing to the end of season one, back when filming a production took place, were you excited approaching the end of this first season or nervous about the future of the show?
詹姆斯说，当我们即将第一季结束时，当拍摄制作开始时，您对第一季即将结束感到兴奋还是对节目的未来感到紧张？
Where were you in your head if you could remember at this time?
如果你当时还记得的话，你的脑子在哪里？
We knew we had a season two.
我们知道我们还有第二季。
I think, didn't we, Josh, or maybe we found out, maybe we found out a little later in season two.
我想，我们不是吗，乔什，或者也许我们发现了，也许我们在第二季晚些时候发现了。
Maybe I'm, we knew before the end of shooting that we had a season two.
也许我是，我们在拍摄结束之前就知道我们有第二季了。
Yeah, it might have been around this time where we got to season two pick up.
是的，可能就在这个时候我们开始了第二季的拍摄。
I remember you guys would kind of come down a set and it looked like ominous, but you guys didn't seem upset.
我记得你们会输掉一盘，看起来很不祥，但你们似乎并不沮丧。
And then you, Pam and Carter would kind of like stand and gather the crew around for just a quick burst, right?
然后你、帕姆和卡特会站起来，把工作人员聚集在一起，快速爆发，对吗？
And you said, just want to let you know that we are coming back for next season.
你说，只是想让你知道我们下赛季会回来。
You know, it's the best feeling in the world.
你知道，这是世界上最好的感觉。
I did that happen by episode 18 or was it right?
我在第18集就这么做了，还是正确的？
Because I don't remember, but somewhere around here, we found that out.
因为我不记得了，但我们在附近的某个地方发现了这一点。
But did that make us not scared and feel like we were fighting for our lives at all times?
但这是否让我们不感到害怕，不觉得我们一直在为自己的生命而战？
No, that lasted for years.
不，这种情况持续了很多年。
And maybe that's a good thing.
也许这是一件好事。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Well, some of these euphoric bursts of joy and showbiz are so short-lived.
好吧，其中一些欣快的喜悦和娱乐圈的爆发是如此短暂。
like maybe it'll last till the end of the day and then you're just back to your set point.
也许它会持续到一天结束，然后你就会回到设定点。
You're back.
你回来了。
Yeah.
是的。
And finally, is Buttercup a real bake shop in New York?
最后，Buttercup 是纽约一家真正的烘焙店吗？
No. That's all we have time for today.
不，我们今天的时间就这么多了。
Well, look, I know we were thinking of Magnolia Bakery, everything and anything, everything about Magnolia Bakery.
好吧，听着，我知道我们在想木兰面包店，所有的一切，关于木兰面包店的一切。
I'm probably a little different, says Brad.
“我可能有点不同，”布拉德说。
Yeah, a little.
是的，有一点。
Yeah, I think so.
是的，我想是的。
We're huge print.
我们是巨大的印刷品。
There's many Princess Bride references and hymiums throughout.
整本书中有很多关于《公主新娘》的参考文献和赞美诗。
So I think probably we were we were not into that because that is God, that's a good movie.
所以我想我们可能不喜欢那个，因为那是上帝，那是一部好电影。
God, there's a good cupcakes and Magnolia.
天啊，这里有美味的纸杯蛋糕和木兰花。
I'm gonna go order some and watch that movie right now.
我现在就去订一些，然后看那部电影。
Thanks everybody!
谢谢大家！
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Z 世代大师）是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
it how we made your mother dot com to sign up for our sub stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
这就是我们如何让您的母亲.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to howyougetyourmerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 howyougetyourmerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters。
Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
Craig Thomas 的首部小说位于 CraigThomasRider.com 斜线小说，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。